algunos minutos en conversatorio junto a
los medios internacionales ha dicho que
en su gobierno no pretende perseguir a
nadie de igual forma también ha dicho
que no pretende interferir en la
justicia y en todo caso también ha dicho
que será la justicia la que determine de
acuerdo a las investigaciones que deba
realizar en este sentido en cuanto a la
relación junto al correo mismo ha
destacado el gesto del ex candidato
andrés arau le ha aparecido inclusive
una actitud de buen gusto y de civismo
la llamada que recibió por parte de
andrés aragón felicitándolo por la
victoria en las elecciones recientes del
día domingo ha dicho que todas las
opciones y todas las acciones que
realice el movimiento de corregimos
serán consideradas como legítima
oposición y ha dicho que la respetará a
mi gobierno no tiene intención de
perseguir a nadie y por el cual
considera inclusive un llamado a la
unidad al movimiento al correísmo para
hacer un gobierno de unidad en los
intereses a favor del país
gustavo hablemos ahora de los
principales retos
para el presidente electo cuáles serán
bueno en principio he hablado un tema
que ha destacado durante toda su rueda
de prensa ofreció de nuevo una rueda de
prensa con medios locales y
posteriormente ofrece un conversatorio
junto a medios internacionales ha dicho
particularmente ha tratado el tema de
venezuela ha dicho y que intentará
impulsar junto a naciones unidas la
regularización de venezolanos durante su
toma de posición ha destacado que él
invitará a juan guaidó aquí considera el
presidente legítimo de venezuela de
igual forma ha dicho que en cuanto a sus
principales retos ha dicho que
continuará el tema humanitario a favor
de los venezolanos y trabajará junto a
la 1 y ha dicho también particularmente
que gobernará en quitó recordemos que
guillermo lazos es proveniente de la
ciudad de guayaquil pero en cuanto a los
principales retos que tú me plantea ha
dicho que luchará específicamente en
contra de la corrupción habla de generar
una economía eficiente también se
mantiene en una propuesta de campaña que
resaltaba que
e intenta conseguir la vacunación de 9
millones de ecuatorianos en sus primeros
11 días parámetros 100 días de gobierno
ahora está bien los resultados
obtuvieron de manera bastante rápida no
obstante el lazo dijo que no recibió
ninguna llamada del ex candidato
indígena ya q pérez quedan atrás
entonces la denuncia de fraude que había
hecho pérez
específicamente durante su conversatorio
junto a medios de comunicaciones ha
dicho que no ha recibido ninguna llamada
del ex candidato ya q pérez pero
específicamente ha dicho ha calificado
el día como un día histórico ha llamado
al encuentro pero fueron las
organizaciones de perdedores
internacionales quienes calificaron esta
mañana en la presentación de sus
informes internacionales fueron siete
las organizaciones junto a la oea que
presentaron informes en cuanto a lo que
sus sugerencias y consideraciones
básicamente
desacreditar y considerar muy
irresponsable l considerar que hubo un
fraude en ecuador ha dicho que en
jugador se cumplió con las elecciones
enmarcadas en los estándares
internacionales y sobre todo destacaron
que se ofrecieron los resultados mucho
antes de la hora prevista destacar o
inclusive el fortalecimiento del sistema
electoral ecuatoriano por el cual han
rechazado cualquier pretensión de
deslegitimar las elecciones realizadas
en ecuador